We now understand that cancer
is a far more complex family of
diseases than previously thought.
And that the results of treatment
in any individual patient
depends on their particular genomic,
proteomic, and metabolic pathways,
other personal factors, and
on similar factors in the cancer.
Given the high mutation rate in cancers,
there's usually
one more than one cell type, essentially
more than one cancer in each patient.
Traditional chemotherapy
is a metabolic poison.
It selectively targets
rapidly growing cells and
works because cancer cells divide
more rapidly than normal cells.
However, our bone marrow,
hair cells, and
the lining of the GI tract
also grow rapidly and
are attacked by the treatments, leading
to side effects that can be awful.
More recently, we've developed
mechanistic treatments that have far
fewer side effects because they
selectively attack metabolic pathways
in the cancer if it has the specific
pathway that the treatment targets.
These are very expensive treatments, and
precious time is lost
if they don't work.
Without an analytic tool,
it's hard to know which patients
will benefit from a therapy.
This research was aimed at
developing a predictive model
to assist physicians in selecting the
right mechanistic drug for each patient.
It's based on a comprehensive model
of known cancer biochemical pathways,
a small part of which is shown here.
The blue boxes are the components.
And the red circles are their
reactions with each other.
The researchers report then when
genomic data from the patient and
from the primary cell types in their
cancer, including cancer stem cells,
if possible, are fed,
the model has successfully predicted
the efficacy of treatment.
It's now being
commercialized by Alacris,
a startup company in Germany
where the research was done.